I'm sorry how much Ranch is the guy
eating hey everyone I'm Abby sharp
welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video we'll be taking a look
at everything that wraps Superstar Jack
Harlow eats in a day and you can pause
the screen or look at the description to
check out my disclaimer including a
trigger warning to those with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating as always please feel free to
skip this video if it's not supportive
to your journey and if you are not
already subscribed hit that subscribe
button and follow me over on Tick Tock
and Instagram at Abby's kitchen before
we get into today's video let's play a
little game called Abby's daily hunger
crushing combo so it's middle of the
afternoon and I'm starting to feel a
little bit of that afternoon dip I'm
also feeling like a little something
sweet so unicorn smoothie with lots of
fresh food some cashew butter and a lot
of Greek yogurt as well Plus
a bill bar puff and not just any puff
folks birthday cake because we can get
through anything when there's some
sprinkles on top all right but guys I
love these not just because they have
sprinkles but because they've got a ton
of protein in every bar and they taste
like chocolate because they're made with
real chocolate like the puff
specifically tastes kind of like a
really delicious marshmallow wrapped in
really good chocolate and this combo
right here she just hits different
um
puffy so if you want to try quilt bars
for yourself check out my link in the
description and use my promo code
abbysharp15 to get 15 off of your order
so this review has come highly requested
from the Harper's Bazaar vault as the
original video has about 2.5 million
views so yeah your girl figured it was a
high time to react let's get into it
eggs baby eggs with the veggies in them
and the seasoning on them and the turkey
love this for him we got protein and
some fat in the eggs in the turkey plus
maybe a bit of fiber and antioxidants in
the veg and there are so many health
benefits when it comes to eating eggs
they're rich in choline which is an
often under consumed nutrient have an
ideal amino acid profile and contrary to
popular belief they don't actually
increase the risk of heart disease or
stroke in the general population we've
also got a lot of research comparing
egg-based breakfast to carb-based
breakfast for weight loss and due to
their exceptionally High satiety profile
eggs always come out on top having said
that that doesn't mean that you need to
shun carbs Exile or death
it's exile
it's old I actually think breakfast is
an ideal time to get in some high fiber
energizing carbs when you need the
energy to like fuel your day so pairing
those eggs with some whole grain toast
or fruit would be a really easy addition
not a coffee drinker I had coffee maybe
three times in my life I like throw Coke
I like to coat my throat I like lemon in
it I like honey in it I like anything
that's good for my throat ah yes there's
always a unicorn who manages to get
through adulthood without succumbing to
the Allure of the dark stuff it is
useless to resist I cannot relate nor
can I really trust anyone like that but
anyway the Throat Coat tea so I looked
this up and it's apparently formulated
with licorice root Wild Cherry Bark
bitter fennel fruit marshmallow root and
slippery elm bark to help to soothe the
throat and as a former singer myself I
can definitely understand its role and
we actually do have some early research
to support some of these herbs potential
use so one city found that slippery elm
bark showed potential for soothing
symptoms of laryngitis and throat
inflammation while another looked at
marshmallow root for its potential in
soothing irritations along the
respiratory tract in general but the
most convincing research we have is for
licorice root which has been shown to
reduce post-operative sore throat when
gargled with for five minutes but that's
like a lot of time to gargle regardless
of the ingredients efficacy all fluids
are good fluids in my books when it
comes to managing a sore throat and the
addition of lemon for some immune
supporting vitamin C and honey for its
evidence-based benefits for an
accompanying cough all sounds like best
practice for me so if the throat coat
stuff works for him then it works for me
I've been eating in the house a lot more
there's a lot of scrambled eggs it's a
lot of turkey sandwiches peanut butter
bananas
cereal all repeat got cereal repeat
honey bunches emotes with almonds in it
Raisin Bran Crunch okay so this food
Diaries episode was apparently filmed
during Peak quarantine and honestly the
statement just brought back like a wave
of triggering covid quarantine Nostalgia
and not in a good way one of the first
things to go during the start of kova
times was date nights at our favorite
restaurants in the city and as a really
big foodie myself it was a sad sad shift
of Affairs to have to like forfeit one
of the favorite highlights of my week
and much like Jack I imagine a lot of
folks who were perhaps used to eating
mostly takeout or restaurant meals had
to develop some basic food skills to try
to feed themselves when we all locked
down as for Jack's go-to quarantine
meals I think these options are super
easy to prepare inexpensive and can
offer a lot of nutrition bang for your
buck so as we already discussed with
Jack's breakfast scrambled eggs offer up
a ton of protein and make it really easy
to throw in some chopped veggies or some
greens for a bit of color and fiber a
turkey sandwich makes for a really easy
assembly and you can mix it up with some
different veggies and spreads and bread
varieties to add more nutrition the PB
Samuel banana is a crowd-pleasing
favorite for good reason because not
only is it really fast and delicious but
it also makes for the perfect hunger
crushing combo because we're getting
protein and fats from the PB and some
Fiber and energizing carbs from the
banana and bread as for the cereal this
guy's speaking my love language Honey
Bunches of Oats is like the most
underrated cereal of all time like argue
with me about it in the comments
but if you want to make it a hunger
crushing combo you can pop it on top of
some Greek yogurt with some berries and
nuts or mix your favorite milk with some
protein powder for the base as I've said
in other interviews big water guy big
water guy over here we also been on the
juice wave since quarantine started a
lot of cranberry a lot of lemonade type
juices trying to stop any kidney stones
from going down hydration is obviously
important for everyone but it's
particularly important for kidney stone
prevention as it helps to flush out the
kidneys and decrease the likelihood of
stone formation however there's really
no research to suggest that cranberry
juice specifically helps to prevent
kidney stones in fact most research has
found that it may actually increase the
risk because cranberry juice is high in
oxalates which can bind to calcium and
increase calcium oxalate kidney stones
it may also decrease the amount of
urinary citric acid excretion and make
the urine pH more acidic which
collectively can increase elect
likelihood of developing a calcium
oxalate or uric acid Stone so other than
drinking just regular water to lower
your kidney stone risk research seems to
suggest that juice is high in citric
acid may help to prevent Stone formation
so if you're particularly prone to
developing kidney stones some great
juice options to help lower your risk
include orange lemon blackcurrant and
grapefruit juice I've been taking too
much sodium and my blood pressure was a
little hard and normal and I told her
I've been eating a lot of ranch
so I've given a bridge during quarantine
I
like the primary culprit of high blood
pressure but I mean if you're consuming
a lot of it I guess it certainly could
tip the scales a quarter cup of ranch
dip has about 20 of the daily
recommended sodium intake so I guess if
he's like going through bottles of it it
could be worth scaling back or trying to
like make your own with some Greek
yogurt and like lots of fresh herbs in
there but while reducing sodium intakes
can absolutely help with blood pressure
readings there are often a lot of other
modifiable and non-modifiable risk
factors at play as well if I were Jack's
dietitian I would be looking at his
potassium intakes through fruits and
vegetables physical inactivity smoking
alcohol intake and stress levels before
swearing off a beloved dip all together
so at the start of quarantine I bought a
treadmill
and I was going crazy on the treadmill
every day exercise is important to me
but I just seem to do it in phases it's
totally normal to get into an exercise
rut where like we oscillate between
hitting the gym really hard and then
dropping off all together and that's
totally okay I find that the best way to
get out of an exercise rut is to really
start small have compassion for yourself
and focus on goals that have nothing to
do with weight or body Aesthetics for me
I know that a gentle walk outside will
help me kind of get out of my head or
clear my anxious thoughts and help me
relax whereas maybe doing some strength
training or cardio in the morning helps
to give me energy for the rest of the
day so I can power through without
burning out and some days I also know
that I just need like a full complete
rest and that's okay too compassion and
kindness is the key to consistency two
three weeks I was on a main dangerous
Cheesesteak streak eating a Cheesesteak
every day
covering in ranch dressing drenching it
around I had to cut that out too why is
the guy taking nutrition and health
advice from his engineer I mean if he
came to a dietitian like me I would say
nothing is inherently bad yes we know
that high intakes of red meat especially
red processed meat can increase
inflammation and increase the risk of
cardiovascular disease and certain
cancers but does that mean you can like
never enjoy a Cheesesteak again
absolutely not it's obvious that
cheesesteaks bring Jack joy and I mean
they're delicious so I totally get that
but Health outcomes can never be reduced
to a single factor and any one single
food is unlikely to have a significant
effect when consumed in moderation we
also can't look at a single food in like
a less nutritious circumstance and
assume that it's bad in all
circumstances so for example if he's
drowning in already high salt high fat
cheesesteak in ranch dressing I can see
a desire to maybe cut back or find an
acceptable alternative but if ranch dip
is helping Jack enjoy more colorful
vegetables which also happen to supply
potassium and fiber then I think it's
definitely well worth keeping in
rotation yeah snake I love chips I'm not
much of a candy fan I like Savory things
I like garden salsa Sun Chips I like
spicy nacho Doritos but I had to give
them up my [ __ ] was Ablaze too many
times okay so normally I don't think we
need to give up any specific foods that
we love but if your [ __ ] is on fire
when you eat a food yeah it's probably
in your best interest to stop eating it
but let's talk about spicy food for a
hot minute that's hot so the sensation
of heat in Foods comes from the compound
capsaicin which can not only irritate
the digestive tract and cause abdominal
pain and heartburn insensitive folks but
it can also pass right through US
undigested in other words if the cup
says decent travels all the way to your
nether regions intact it's not likely
going to feel so good coming out the
other end I'm not sure how much real
capsaicin is in like Doritos but
regardless if you're getting the spicy
runs it's probably best to opt for like
a basic potato chip and call it a day
dinner could be anywhere from 6 p.m to
midnight Studio life seems to always end
up being Sarpino's Pizza in my prime or
even you could say my darkest days I was
eating like eight slices
I totally get that late nights in the
studio May warrant a pizza run
Pizza time but this is 2022. there are
hundreds of doordash options open late
and since sodium does seem to be an
issue for Jack possibly due to blood
pressure or kidney stones which are also
impacted by salt I would try to switch
up the dinner routine and if it's gonna
be a pizza night amazing maybe add in a
little side salad for some extra
potassium and fiber to keep us feeling
satiated on fewer than like eight slices
that way we get our pizza but we keep
our sodium in check Chick-fil-A is a
cheat meal despite how terribly I'm
already living it's a cheat meal
nonetheless because it immediately just
makes me slower and tired so this really
speaks to the importance of tuning into
our body's true physical Sensations to
serve as a guide for making food
decisions I'm sure Jack has like a super
crazy schedule and if Chick-fil-A like
slows them down and makes them feel
sluggish he may just intuitively want to
choose it last less often not because
it's bad or because you are bad for
eating it but because it just doesn't
make him feel good I feel like Cinnabons
like a perfect example of something that
you just you just gave up that day I
never feel good about myself after I
finish one of those food is so much like
sex to me
and you can tell how healthy my
relationship with sex must be I'm
telling you it's so regretful sometimes
so food and
students related as they're really two
of life's greatest pleasures and also
biological needs but feeling regret
guilt or shame after either can be a
really big red flag if your body doesn't
feel great after eating Chick-fil-A or a
Cinnabon then use that experience as
data to inform our future food decisions
but it shouldn't be a reflection of you
being a bad person who has made some
kind of like regretful terrible mistake
eat the cinnamon bun gather and
acknowledge the data and move on
grilled cheese I love a late night
grilled cheese it is like honestly my
favorite Lazy Girl dinner I also think
that despite being branded a junk food
by a lot of people grilled cheese can
actually be a pretty versatile meal with
ample room for adding nutritional value
for instance you can add some apple or
caramelized onions for some sweetness
maybe mash up some avocado for a dose of
healthy fats and creaminess or even
layer on some basil and tomato for like
a Caprese style grilled cheese the
flavor options and nutritional boosters
are literally endless so to summarize I
kind of felt like this interview was
like a list of all the foods that Jack
Loves eating but that he's had to cut
out I didn't hear a lot of insight into
what he's replaced all of these beloved
snacks and meals with and I think that
that's actually really important when we
focus on what we need to cut out or
restrict we get stuck in scarcity
mentality and it can leave us longing
for those Foods even more so rather than
going from 100 to zero on all the foods
he enjoys I would love to see him focus
on what he can add to his meals to
really round out the nutrition and
satiety and I think this is a really
good lesson for a lot of folks who are
struggling with a similar mentality at
home but on that note my sick is
growling and I'm craving a Cinnabon like
crazy right now so that is all that I
have for you guys today if you like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on who or what
if you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye oh
my God I need to eat foreign
[Music]